hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from this year's U.S
Championship it is Fabiano caruana vs
Alexander Linderman and this is a game
that was actually played in round seven
the reason I'm showing it now because
even though uh the finale was very
intense it was
um uh well Fabi drew his game very
quickly in the final round against Lavon
arunan and it was up to Ray Robson will
he be able to beat uh Jeffrey Sean and
force Ty bricks against Fabi if he does
not win then Fabi is the clean winner as
he went into the final round a half a
point ahead of uh Ray Robson uh Robson
was unable to do it he uh he only got a
draw and that means that Fabi is the
2022 US champion so I just I decided to
show you this game with everything
that's been happening I I was able to
cover all of the games that I wanted to
but it's such a nice one really shows
the absolute class and I'm sure you guys
are going to enjoy it so let's dive
straight into it like I said from round
seven against Alexander Linderman Fabi
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn the C4 at the English opening we
have C6 Pawn to D for N Pawn to D5 sorry
about that
we have Knight to F3 by Fabi and now
Knight to F6 uh the the slav defense is
on the board we have Queen to C2 and the
D captors and C4 abandoning the center
very early on but this is all very
standard stuff Ponte E4 now upon the B5
defending the C4 pawn and now Fabi just
undermines it with Pawn to B3 C captures
a captures and now Pawn to E6 and if you
count the pawns you will see that Fabi
is down a pawn but this is a well-known
line where white will get compensation
for this and it's also a line where one
might seek a win with the white pieces
and here Bishop to D2 is the move that
everyone plays but five he played Bishop
to D3 and there are only a handful of
games with uh Bishop to D3 and now we
have Ponte A6 and it is now already as
of movate that we have a completely new
game so very exciting stuff very early
on the idea is the standard one you
defend the B5 Pawn so you can advance
this Pawn to C5 and undermine uh White
strong Center he will put the B7 Knight
beta D7 The Rook will come to C8 and
well the usual stuff pretty much so
castles with Bishop to E7 Knight the C3
and the now Bishop to B7 we have rooked
the D1 aligning The Rook nicely with the
queen and pawn to H6 now the pawn might
be a problem with all of this uh Bishop
Queen action and this diagonal once you
push E5 the Knight will have to move the
H7 will be undefended so H6 definitely
makes sense and here Fabi makes a very
tricky move he plays Queen E2 and it's
such a nice move of keeping the black
king in the center of the board the
problem is that black castles black is
already lost due to this queen to E2
move uh funny stuff I know but look at
this E5 now the Knight has to move
Knight to D5 you are attacking the
undefended Knight on C3 but now Queen E4
you threaten Checkmate and the only way
to deal with this sufficiently is to
play G6 but this is such a weakening of
Black's position
uh that you can't simply defend okay now
you have the capture because the Knight
on C3 is hanging so let's say characters
captures attacks the queen now Queen E3
goes after the pawn here and again no
good way to defend this you're you're
gonna have to play some like Bishop G5
now captures captures and now don't
capture but rather Queen H3 open up a
discovery from the bishop Force the
trade on H5 and now after captress
captures and captures then the H5 Pawn
will fall as well and this is now a
completely winning end game for white so
this is why you cannot Castle after
Queen D2 important to know sunlight beat
the D7 we have Pawn to E5 and now Knight
to D5 attacking the Knight on C3 so
Knight captures on d5c captures and not
Knight the E1 now the queen can come to
G4 put pressure on on uh Black's King
side and now Queen to B6 the pawn is now
uh free for grabs and you don't have to
worry about any discoveries from the
bishop as for the moment the bishop
cannot deliver check but okay not also
too crazy to just grab the pawn you
first have to check if it's possible to
grab it so here Queen to G4 goes after
the G7 Pawn G6 and now Bishop Bishop to
D2 just continuing development
and now the queen also guards the D4
Pawn so nowhere is there and pawn to B4
uh of course what else are you gonna
play Ponte 5.84 is the idea then you
will uh have created a past Pawn on uh
on the B file we have Bishop to E3 by
Fabi and now Pawn to A5 uh uh okay Ponte
five makes sense this this was the plan
all along but now Queen to E2 here you
might have some ideas of capturing and
G6 the problem is there's just not
enough compensation yes you've you've
captured the two pawns the Black Ink it
might be a little bit weak but the black
king is surprisingly safe on d8 there is
no good way to continue for example Rook
ac1 okay you want to cut off the king uh
not Knight to f8 let's say attacks the
queen queen has to move now Rook H7
attacks the Queen Once the queen moves
now Bishop A6 and you are playing this
without um so much problems you will
condest The Rook on C1 at some point
with some like Rook to ca that the
bishop can't really come into play uh
and the the queen don't really have to
worry about the queen so a black defends
this uh easily so instead Queen back to
EQ by Fabi and now King to f8 now with
some ideas of even King the G7 castling
artificial you can't just Castle because
the H6 spawn Falls but you can play King
G7 and then bring the Rook into the game
so here G3 we have Bishop to A6 offering
a trait of Bishops and now Pawn to H4 we
have font H5 not allowing Pawn to H5 by
Fabi and now Knight to F3
grabbing hold of that G5 square or
rather preparing to grab hold of the G5
Square King to G7 and now Bishop to G5
forcing Linderman to make a decision as
the bishop on E7 is hanging so Rook H
the E8 you could also just trade
everything captures and captures but for
the moment uh first Rook to E8 now black
has successfully Castle artificially and
now Rook D to C1
probably not interested in being the
first uh to start capturing pieces but
now Linderman does so Bishop captures on
D3 Queen captures bishop captress and G5
Knight captures in just The Rook 8 to C8
and it would seem Lenderman has solved
all of his uh developing problems now
it's merely a question of how how to
activate the Knight on D7 and okay if
ever Queen to F3 going after the F7
point you can always play Rook D7 so
it's not a problem soaking the G2 by
Fabi first improving the position of his
King and now uh the the problem for
black is that it's really not easy to
activate the Knight on D7 and it's also
not easy to find any any viable plan for
example if Rook captures on C1 which is
something you want to play let's say
Road captures now it's a white who
controls the C file but even if you try
something like A4 to create a pass Pawn
okay a captures B3 the problem is
there's a rook C3 and now you can no
longer yeah defend if B2 just Rook to B3
and if you move The Rook here then Queen
F3 is a very problematic now there you
cannot defend the F7 Pawn uh by any
other means by then by moving the rule
back to f8 and if you do this then you
lose the B3 Pawn so it you know there
are some ideas here but nothing really
works so you might try some like Queen
A7 to prepare a for you can play Rook to
A8 to play A4 but it's nothing uh
nothing you wanna play and be proud of
it or you know just be happy about it so
it's it's a very hard position for black
and Lenderman finds a very nice idea of
Pawn to F6 and okay e captures an F6
Knight captures now he will be able to
shift the Knight over to E4 where the
Knight will be very strong you have
crippled your king side a little bit but
obviously he knows what he's doing and
Fabi plays Queen to E2 uh
uh just uh putting the the the the queen
and the E file going after the E6 pawn
and this is very very important because
now in order to play this or in order to
even survive this position uh Alexander
needs to play Knight to E4 and it seems
odd because it's it's a straight out
Pawn sacrifice uh Knight character spawn
captures and queen captures and now you
would have to play Rook the C3 you go
after the B3 Pawn also The Rook is very
very unpleasant on this diagonal uh
Queen to E5 check you even give up
another Pawn let's say King to H7 now
Rook captures on c3b captures and Rook
captures on A5 or even Queen characters
on A5 you offer a queen trade now Queen
B7 trick and after the king moves Pawn
to C2 and the past C2 Pawn will give
sufficient compensation to Alexander uh
for the uh for for being done upon so
that's how you play this position
however in the game he played King to G8
makes sense you also don't want this
Knight captures an E6 to ever come with
the check if it happens uh but it also
blenders the game completely but it's
not all that clear how you have to
really really spot it so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
what uh Linderman missed here while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
A5 Pawn is hanging if you found that
then you truly are a grand master
material and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
first Rook captures on C8 we remove one
of the Defenders of the E6 spawn Rook
captures on C8 and now Rook captures on
A5 with the idea of removing the other
defender of the E6 pawn and of course
the Rook cannot be captured if you
capture The Rook it then comes a
beautiful mating attack Queen captures
on E6 connecting with the Rook but uh in
most lines you are really not interested
in that rock for example King G7 Queen
E7 check and now you're either getting
checkmated or okay if you go to H6 then
you have to suffer some windmill action
Knight to F7 check of course you can't
go here so you have to go back now night
the D6 check okay you will collect the
road king H6 Knight captures and C8 and
it seems like okay maybe you're fine
you're just down a pawn but you cannot
survive this attack let's say queen A6
you have to guard the Knight on F6 now
Queen the f8 to check King H7 Queen to
F7 check King H6 and now Knight to E7
attacking uh the G6 Pawn this will be
Checkmate and now the only way to defend
is to move the Knight but once you move
at night the G8 is the other Checkmate
so there you have it what happens if you
capture The Rook so is there a counter
play without capturing The Rook a very
unlikely so Rook to E8 was played uh
bringing back the defender of the E6
Pawn but now Rook the A6 by Fabi now
tripling up on the attack so The Rook
also attacks the E6 pawn queen captures
on D4 and now a rook captures on E6
threatening to capture The Rook here so
Rook to f8 you can't trade if you trade
Queen captures an E6 will be pretty much
the same attack Queen to C2 now going
after the weak G6 spawn and again
there's no good way to defend it if you
play King G7 then just rookie 7 check if
King H6 okay the Knight covers the H7
Square so you cannot deliver Checkmate
but look at this queen C1 with all sorts
of nasty discoveries being threatened uh
there's just no way out of this if
Knight G4 let's say you threatened the
df2 pawn just rooked H7 Checkmate so you
can't move the Knight you can't not move
the knight uh I mean whatever you do the
Knight will just move and I mean it will
either be mate in one or depending on
what black plays you will you will
either maybe win the queen or you will
win the Rook so this is completely lost
it's actually made in five but you know
you can pretty much move the pieces
anywhere and you will still win so after
Queen to C2 Knights the E4 was played
blocking the Queens reach to the G6 Pawn
but now you have to give it up because
Rook captures on G6 with check King to
h8 and now Rook the H6 check King to G8
and now only now Knight captures on e4
D captures on e4 and now Rook captures
an H5 so okay Lenderman finds a way to
survive he continues the game but he's
down two pawns but that's important in
chess sometimes you just need to survive
and hope that your opponent blunders the
game because as you know that does
happen in chess so Queen to F6 now
threatening uh some action along the f
file but it's nothing concrete just Rook
the G5 check King to h8 and now Queen to
E2 the pawn is guarded you're
threatening Queen to H5 check this will
be instant resign so here Linderman has
to go into a rook end game in order to
just continue Queen F3 check Queen
characters e captures with check King H3
and now Rook the C8 hoping to grab that
F2 Pawn maybe he can advance his F Pawn
to become a queen but that's a lot of
moves so Rook G4 by Fabi Rook the C2 now
Rook captures on B4 and Rook captures on
C2 so now it's three pawns to one
Lenderman does have a pass pawn and and
F3 but it's very very hard to actually
push that pawn
so King G4 Rook to F1 and now Rook the
B7 cutting off the black king and now
fabi's plan is very simple you will just
Advance your B Pawn and win the game as
one usually does and here the if F2 it's
not a problem just King F3 now you can't
move the Rook otherwise the pawn hangs
if you don't move the Rook then King G2
will attack the rook and the pawn so you
will win that pawn and regardless of
what black plays so Lenderman doesn't
even try he just shuffles the king back
and forth uh and waits for Fabi to push
the pawn before he resigns so Pawn to B4
King h8 Pawn to B5 King G8 Pawn to B6
King to h8 and now Rook the B8 check
King taji uh King to G7 Pawn to B7 and
he was in this position on move 51 that
Alexander Linderman resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
whatever you're playing if you play Pawn
to F2 it's merely a matter of Rook G to
check you sacrifice The Rook to bring
your queen into the game with Tempo and
now it doesn't really matter what you do
the the Queen will give a few checks and
then collect the Rook on F1 and if you
don't do that uh again well if player
will be want to to put pressure on this
you just play King captures and F3
doesn't really matter up three pawns
completely winning
so yeah very nicely played by both of
them brilliant the game by by Linderman
brilliantly defending and even maybe it
was even a better position for him
throughout the entire game until this uh
ill-advised King to G8 move I mean uh
just leaving leaving too much uh the the
G6 spawn hanging and then allowing five
euro captures on A5 but you know you you
can't see everything if you could see
everything you would be world champion
even the world champion doesn't see
everything
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh if you guys are interested
in the final standings here they are the
final standings of the US Championship
2022 Fabiano caruana wins it wins 60 000
followed by Ray Robson who was in
Pursuit for the entire tournament this
was one of his uh better tournaments
maybe even his best tournament uh so far
so congratulations to him as well in
third place linear Dominguez a Wonder
Lee and Wesley so Jeffrey Sean uh Sam
Shanklin Samuel Savion uh Han smoke and
Neiman levonne that is Alexander
Linderman Christopher you and Elsa
moradia body uh in last place uh and
also if you guys are interested what
does this mean for the for the ratings
Fabi even won some ratings here so you
can see these are the world's top 25
players in classical chess uh Carlson
and ding still the only 2800 players
then you have in the third and fourth
Yani promise
in fifth uh I think he he went up one
one place because Wesley dropped three
places so that's why why Nakamura is now
number five even though he hasn't played
any classical chess uh Fabiano went up
to places so he is now uh in number six
then gearing seven Wesley Nate Ananda
still in Ninth Place incredible stuff uh
kariak intent and then all of the others
and you can see gookish and erigasi
Arjun still doing very well number
number 22 and number 25.
uh so yeah that's the game those were
the standings hope you guys enjoyed that
uh very nicely played by Fabi winning
another title of US champion we'll see
uh we'll we'll see what what comes next
for him a very very exciting stuff I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to jjorn bierkman and I would like to
thank revision reptiles YouTube Trevor
Terrace
and Alan cycle for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day